okay [ __ ] we're [ __ ] back we are
[ __ ] back and yeah the schedule
because a little nutty for my taste and
I will not even my type but it's
whatever let's get to the time in the
Chinese
I chinet me
[ __ ] dark here today anyway how that
went down today you know you don't get a
blow job so I got a blow job today I
didn't I did not get a blow job guys
anyway so I'm playing this game i Justi
not keeping a coal taping of life she's
gonna fresh most of all you know I don't
want any go down here but not get a big
guy yeah yeah [ __ ] Jax no other suck
a dick off his back
[ __ ] okay let's go the yellow jack
hey betches what can I get for you
you're still banned what what about
these two who ever win get banned one
fan him we do need a ban him he's my god
damn husband he's young enough to be
your son ain't the internet a beautiful
thing uh yeah yeah yeah anyway I saved
your husband give me a drink I got a
meeting okay but any more bodies turn up
in my bar I swear I will not serve you
mr. Phillips your is yeah it's Jang
pleasure to move on no I am mr. Chang
humble translator mr. Chang now what are
some others sensors one fell off and
vanish make it good gather the telchine
is pleased to meet your quizzes oh yeah
he seems it Warsaw princes nice assured
I holla oh you're calm Utada like
invader walk since the war in singsong
play mail Oh car is wrong with him
Jessica chooses to go night night night
what fat [ __ ] I'm out no don't go please
I beg you if you go his father kill me
why do I give a [ __ ] you don't we hear
that Trevor Phillips cooperation is
serious business we pay good price
things work out we partners make big
money well
let me show you the operation I kind of
a [ __ ] Tammy sir Chang
I'm like coming down to see the kid kid
you can't get here quick enough the ad
seconds are coming they think you took
out Ortega they ain't mistaken won't get
down here and take them out too okay
okay see your boss someone this drank
for his own personal consumption no no
mr. Chang Cena is very specific he wants
a good reliable source of
methamphetamine we will buy from you
here and distribute losing established
network I'm worried that might dilute
what our operations all about and that
let's def at a TED Trevor we ain't got
long oh whoa whoa manners chef these are
our guests all right we I mr. Chang and
his humble servant nice to meet you as
ever we ain't got long till they give
you everything in its time all right
gentlemen please come check out the
storage facility hi apple room inside
mr. King please sir if you will let me
out you will recommend shortly gentlemen
had gone yes
let's say that bench I knew where Ivan
visitors hello briefly
but yeah
now I really am gonna put you out of
business
[Music]
come on
keep you catalysis a life
clean em up yeah come on they ran this
case we got to deal with us like
drinking hi yes but I out
[Music]
look out on the last night they get the
whole contingent here
bye
so we have here any second where's the
rest of them a around the back of
building all right let's do the fishes
good God
get off my property
[Music]
good
knock knock
and
[ __ ] hey
[Music]
looking for you is a dangerous mrs. we
need to get to the front of the shop
come on yeah yeah
[Music]
get down they're coming from the door
[Music]
[Music]
yes satis the law I got [ __ ] blood
away
ok rocket dog
go back to the lab and give me a damage
report we got to let our special
business partners out of the ice shack
there 150 tour gentlemen I think we have
seen quite enough guys Josh ahem you
don't all swing by and sign the
contracts all right just ignore the body
he covered are we still gonna cut that
back [ __ ] yeah guys guys
that was down south that guy